a twelve year old girl is spearheading a
campaign to legalize medical marijuana
across the whole country
Alexis Portal says she and her family
had no choice but to move from their
Texas home to Colorado to treat her
severe epilepsy now her family and a
handful of others are suing Attorney
General Jeff Sessions and the DEA
they're demanding cannabis for the
treatment of their illnesses diseases
and medical conditions Barry Petersen
spoke with Alexis he is in Denver
Colorado with her story
Barry good morning good morning well
here at medicine man they grow a lot of
the marijuana that they use in their pot
products
now even though marijuana is legal in
Colorado for recreational use there's
still a debate about its value to treat
medical conditions but one family thinks
this is nothing less than a lifesaver
well ever since I've been on this
cannabis I've actually been seizure-free
for today it's 974 days so we're coming
up on a thousand so I think that's
pretty good pretty good indeed because
this was once the life the whole exes
Bartel seizures every few days as seen
in these videos taken at the direction
of her doctors her parents say epilepsy
medications didn't work and there was
even talk of brain surgery what do you
call epilepsy well I call it my seizure
monster but this seems to tame the
seizure monster and oil made from
marijuana taken twice a day her family
lived in Texas when they couldn't get
the oil they needed but they could in
Colorado were both medical and
recreational pot are allowed for her
father Dean bore tell the decision to
move here three years ago was an easy
one I would die for her right so the
least I could do is uproot my life and
give her a chance at the exact same
freedoms and future I had you'd do it
again twice on Sunday are you adjusted
to being here oh we've been here about
three years so we're adjusting alexis
hopes the lawsuit we make medical
marijuana legal across the country do
you think it's unfair that this medicine
is not available
to everybody in the United States I
think it's really unfair because I feel
like they're basically punishing us
because we're sick but some medical
experts are not sure
Jacqueline French is the chief
scientific officer of the Epilepsy
Foundation we really need more research
to find out what's helping what's
hurting whether people should opt for
this over some other options that they
may have alexis has turned her epilepsy
into her cause making soap and donating
the proceeds to charity even writing a
book but all she really wants is just to
be a kid and as it make you also feel
more normal in your regular life yes one
because I can let's say have a sleepover
at a friend's house without having a
seizure why did you think people would
listen to a twelve-year-old well I feel
like it wouldn't really matter because
it's the right thing to do and I don't
think I need to be over 18 to do the
right thing
the DEA and the Justice Department both
turned down a request for an interview
as for Alexis she lives this new normal
one day at a time but she hopes that the
marijuana means the seizure monster will
never come back
Vlad absolutely Barry Peterson thank you
very much